a bloodline in shambles and a midnight
bargain with fate Mike Flanigan's newest
Netflix series is pure po but what does
it all mean will be The Telltale Heart
here is the Twisted ending of The Fall
of the House of Usher explained spoilers
ahead The Fall of the House of Usher
splits its story across three timelines
the main narrative sees rodick Usher
provide his confession to his longtime
investor August dupan while they sit in
the dilapitated Usher home rodick
recalls the recent events that have
claimed the lives of his children in
mysterious fashion which make up the
second timeline but he also explains how
his past actions have led to their fate
unsettling Visions plag rodderick as he
tells a harrowing story interspersed
between this conversation is a walk down
memory lane to witness Rod's and his
twin sister melin's rise to power we
follow them from their humble beginnings
and the tragic passing of their mother
Eliza to their burning ambition to take
over the pharmaceutical industry through
the Fortunato company and the Miracle
painkiller known as liadon a young dupan
also features here as he tries to
convince rodk to do the right thing and
turn in the Fortunato CEO Rufus grizwald
for his Shady dealings across all
timelines one common denominator remains
a mysterious woman known as Vera who
appears to have the supernatural power
to shape shift and deliver Wicked
Justice on the spoiled user children
however the relationship between her
Roderick and meline isn't made clear
until the final episode when all is
revealed about how their paths crossed
the title fall occurs in the series
eighth and final episode Rodrick Usher
reveals to Augustine dupan that he and
his sister meline bured for chinato CEO
Rufus Griswald behind a wall that
evening they headed to a bar to build an
alibi there they met the bartender verer
who presented them with a falan deal
they will never suffer legal
consequences for the rest of their lives
and can use Fortunato for whatever they
want altruism or enrichment but there's
a catch of course just before you would
have died rodri just before you would
have died anyway
your bloodline dies with you they
accepted the deal hence the deaths of
roderick's children what breaks rodick
though is a passing of his granddaughter
Lenor whom he regards as the best of
everyone that finally wakes him up to
the gravity of their bargain however
Vera recognizes the child's virtue and
makes it painless and she tells Lenor
how her death will end up being the
Catalyst for millions of lives being
saved in the future back at the Usher
house rodick confesses to dupan that he
was always aware that greed and ambition
would consume his I knew I would climb
to the top of the tower on a pile of
corpses he also reveals that he poisoned
and killed meline leaving her in the
basement however she isn't dead rising
and strangling Roderick to death as
tupan rushes out and watches the House
of Usher
collapse about as subtle as a tumbling
building The Fall of the House of Usher
doesn't play around with its message or
theme the title signifies both The End
Of The Bloodline and the family's Legacy
well rodri and meline Usher are obsessed
of taking over for chato and and using
it to build an Unstoppable Empire it all
comes to not but from their rashes hope
rises the last remaining long blood
related ushers are Juno roderick's
second wife and Morel Frederick's wife
and Leno's mother they decide to use
their inheritance for good rather than
repeat the cycle of pain Juno inherits
roderick's Fortune but she dismantles
Fortunato and starts the Phoenix
Foundation to help treat addiction or
ver reveals that Morel eventually
recovers from her horrific injuries and
inherits a sizable amount of money gives
most of it away but she uses a rest to
set up the nonprofit Leno foundation in
honor of her daughter which saves
millions of lives around the world the
flashback sequences showcase Roderick
Usher with his first wife Annabelle Lee
and his eldest children Tam Lane and
Frederick while the family isn't living
in the lap of luxury or experiencing the
lifestyle of the Rich and Famous there
are fleeting moments that indicate a
pure happiness that is never reached
again the love between rodder and
Annabelle comes across as genuine and
judging by Rod's poetic remembrance of
her is something he never finds again
and we loved for a love that was more
than a love I and my
Anabell Rod's obsession with power and
money blinds him to what's important in
life even when his children pass he
doesn't appear to be too devastated by
their death since money has already
created a wedge between them all they
fail to appreciate each other only
focusing on what they can gain for
selfish purposes it's only when rodick
loses his granddaughter who never asked
for anything from him that he real
realizes all the money in the world
means nothing in the end after the death
of the ushers August dupan summarizes
the situation perfectly he explains that
he is set to go home and spend time with
his family which makes him the richest
man in the world meanwhile rodick dies
without his fortune or affection from
his family in essence he perishes as the
poorest man on Earth The Fall of the
House of Usher not so subtly addresses
the opioid crisis and the controversial
role of pharmaceutical companies valuing
profits over Health while the Young
rusher believes in the power of liadon
as a non-addictive painkiller he
realizes this is a fallacy and there was
never an Earnest intention to help
others only to make money by any means
necessary in the final episode Verna
forces V to come to terms with his
actions at the Fortunato officers as he
Witnesses hordes of bodies dropping from
the high-rise building to the ground she
reminds him that these are all the
deaths that the ushers and Fortunato
have caused over the decades while
building their empire on the suffering
and pain of others on another level both
m and rodick are solely responsible for
the deaths of their family they doom
their bloodline through their bargain
with verer not one stopping to think of
the long-term implications for
short-term returns for them their
ambition and immediate desires Trump
consequence or the ability to let others
choose their own Destinies they
ultimately become grim reapers as they
sentence their family members to death
through their acts of selfishness and
self-indulgence the extent of verna's
powers remain unclear in The Fall of the
House of aser though there's no denying
that she can see into the past present
and future of every individual in the
seventh episode drawing Frederick user's
death verer reveals to him that an
alternate future existed if rodick and
meline hadn't accepted her offer their
decision changed his life forever a
dentist that's the funniest part that's
what you were going to be in the other
life it all but indicates that events
would have turned out differently for
everyone had the Usher twins chosen
differently on that fateful night rodick
and meline are aware of this too
believing the end of their bloodline is
a fair price to pay for ensuring their
family never struggles in life they
would rather risk it all and embrace
corruption than live with the anxiety of
being ordinary and struggling to achieve
anything however there's yet another
possible Branch here even if the ushers
are taken verna's offer they could have
still used the opportunity to turn
Fortunato into a Force for good she
leaves the choice in their hands we're
sitting outside of time in
space this is the moment while it's
unlikely the out would have been
different since a deal is a deal here
the ushers might have left a better mark
on the World to their actions and become
revered for it rather than reviled in
Edgar Alano's The Fall of the House of
Usher the closeness of the relationship
between rodick and meline Usher has long
been disputed one score of thought
suggests that they may share a strong
psychic Bond often found in stories
about twins however a conflicting view
presumes that they may have been lovers
the show also illustrates an extreme
closeness between the siblings as meline
and rodderick appear to be glued the hip
in their early years while growing apart
later on in their lives however any
indication of them being lovers is
quickly dispelled and meline reveals
that she is attracted to women and has
no interest in men plus the two never
engage in any kind of behavior to
suggest otherwise with regards to the
ASA twins Mike Flanagan and his team
don't lean too much into them having any
type of psychic link instead he uses
their Mutual shared desire for power and
ambition that's the main driver for what
brings and keeps them close they believe
Fortunato and its riches are their
Birthright and that they should become
the king and queen of the company cheers
to
you Cleopatra the short story The Fall
of the House of Usher doesn't feature a
lot of protagonists and antagonists in
fact the three main characters are
rodick Usher his sister meline and the
unnamed narrator of the story more the
Netflix show utilizes certain elements
from this premise it also puts its own
spin on Matters by introducing a wealth
of characters and themes from other
Edgar aleno tales for example August
dupan is based on C August dupan a
detective from a few other post stories
on the show dupan steps into the
narrator spot becoming the person whom
rodick spills the beans too similarly
the names of the characters take
inspiration from figures introduced in
POS poems and stories Lenor Annabelle
Lee and even the name of their company
Fortunato are just a few examples among
many arguably the biggest addition to
the show is verer but even that's a Sly
po wink the name is an anagram for Raven
to this day the Raven of course remains
one of Po's most memor able Works mom
used to tell us that Ravens were the
minions of Satan cuz Noah thre them
overboard and they still survived the
flood much like Mike Flanigan's other
projects The Fall of the House of Usher
ends on a conclusive note and doesn't
tease a second season the story provides
a definitive beginning middle and end
putting the Usher family 6 ft under by
the time the credits roll and know that
isn't a hands that pops out of the Grave
to signify someone will be back as a
zombie August Tan's narration at the end
of the final episode also provides
answers to any questions the audience
may have about the fate of the remaining
characters in addition he reveals how
the usha's lawyer Arthur Pim serves a
lifetime jail sentence and accepts it
without any fight as he takes the full
for fortunato's controversial practices
dupan also discloses how his case is now
shut and over for most of his adult life
he was consumed of taking down the
ushers but now with them being dead he
can finally rest since Mike Flanigan
approached The Fall of the House of user
as a wider tribute to Edgar alm's body
of work rather than a straightforward
adaptation of the master of maab
original short story the possibilities
for various spin-offs exist first off
the most natural character to transition
to other stories is verer since Vera is
a shape shifter this means any potential
further installments in Flanigan's po
Universe could continue with or without
act Carla Gino's involvement however
after her phenomenal performance on the
show not to mention her multiple
collaborations with Flanagan it's likely
most fans would want to see her return a
second character that merits further
exploration is Arthur PIM in this story
Pim remains loyal to the ushers and acts
as their lead attorney as well as their
fixer objection sustained their lead
attorney Pim doesn't feature in The Fall
of the House of user short story but he
is from Po's 1838 novel The Narrative of
Arthur Gordon Pim of nanak elements of
this tale feature in the retelling of
Pimp's enigmatic backstory and his
eyebrow raising Journey filled with all
sorts of horror and tribulation could be
turned into its own terrifying
miniseries whether or not any of that
happens is anyone's guess but fans of
both POS and Flanagan's work can still
enjoy The Fall of the House of Usher as
a satisfying Standalone tale to the
House of
Usher whose time has
come